jay-z's time on instagram has already
come to an end so just one day after
joining the platform and amassing over
1.8 million followers he has deactivated
his account
[Music]
yeah jay-z's now deleted first post uh
was shared on his feed and his story it
was a promo poster for the new western
the harder they fall which he produced
uh and wrote the music for the
deactivation of his account comes after
the movie was released on netflix uh see
what he did there yeah pull the song
yeah i mean he was being a good producer
he was putting out on social media and
then he's like i'm out uh now we may not
see jay-z on instagram anymore but we
will see him interviewed on the streets
by a very adorable young girl named
jazzy
yeah this is adorable uh jay-z shared a
few tips for success to the young kids
and it's all about believing in yourself
having confidence and then like
believing in yourself even more take a
look
hey guys it's jazzy and i'm here in new
york city and we're about to interview
mr sean carter yo i'm making sure turn
gold when the weather flows yes put away
the leathers and put ice on the go let's
go just to see one of us making to all
the kids that have dreams of being
successful like you what advice can you
give them be successful like me
okay believe in yourself even for anyone
else believes in you
now tuned into the greatest got that
ultimate confidence like you do you're
very confident thank you
i'll show you how to do this son yeah
and just just believe in yourself